on tour yep following the band tool
that's right right yeah and initially
how did that come up
well we myself and a Nick and Freddie
Scott we are all obsessed with the band
tool went to see them in LA we didn't
the three of us didn't really know each
other that well if if at all really and
we decided to get dinner before the
concert chatted about it we're like oh
man we're all in deep we all love this
band
yeah and Nick made a joke at some point
he was like if they announce more dates
we should just follow them do our shows
to make money to buy tickets to see
their shows and we kind of laughed about
it and then when they announce more
dates I started thinking about it and I
was like oh this is this is one of those
unique things where even if we make no
money and even if you know whatever when
we promote this no one else will be
promoting this type of thing of course
and so I was like oh maybe there's some
traction in that yeah and so we decided
to to book some dates follow them I went
on Conan he was like do you have
something to promote and I was like well
I'm doing this tour I could announce
that yeah yeah so I went on and joked
about that the guitarist for the band
saw that he messaged me and he was like
I'll hook up tour passes and you guys
can like come to the shows so right out
of the gate I was like hey we don't to
take the money we're making buy tickets
he's like hooking it up so right out of
the gate we were like floor seats eighth
row backstage passes we went backstage
right after the show we like met him he
so he let us do this every night after
their shows it got to a point where it
was known we would just walk back there
and hang out his whole crew we'd start
going back there they like god it's
these guys all right just he's back like
through there and so we kind of met the
other members of the band that way and
then I it this is my favorite band since
I was 16 oh my god and now here we are
in their world and and maybe because of
this the business that we're in of
entertainment in general you the the the
illusion of things being magical behind
the curtain we already know it's not
that's
you know what I mean like you already
know like Oh everyone's people and
behind the curtain everyone's just doing
a job yeah yeah and so going into it I
was like oh I I hope that that's what
this is yeah and going behind the
curtain I was like oh yeah these are for
dads who are very good at their band and
they're just very normal right very nice
there's no ego at all about how
successful they are they even thanked me
for going on Conan and talking about
their band what and I was like you're
welcome but you sell out 20,000 seats I
don't know if you need me doing great
it's [ __ ] funny because because Nick
used to be my opening act for many years
and he would go on and on about the the
band tool yeah right how they're you
know up there in terms of like the
Beatles and whatnot right and in my mind
I'm like there's no way and so I don't
go to I don't have a CD player I buy
everything off of [ __ ] iTunes and
[ __ ] yeah
right and so I didn't know anything
about tool so I would Google it I may go
to iTunes tool and it would cut two
things would come up and they were like
songs about hammers and here I mean like
not the fan tool but I would listen to
it like preview it the hammer goes like
this like this is ridiculous what
happened was the screwdriver says to the
Hammerhead the Beatles he thinks this is
the beetle so then what happened was as
soon as they put their stuff online
right I asked all the album's yeah
and I listened to them from beginning to
end and let me tell you something you
truly did do that it's what I gone I
love that you did that listening to it
and initiative in the beginning you know
once you start listening I think I
didn't start with the first album I
think I start with the newest one Yeah
right
yeah from beginning to end yeah and it's
like a journey yeah but I also love you
know I grew up with Metallica and I like
harder stuff as well
yes but this is a few
between that and something artistic and
like Pink Floyd yeah and like it's like
psychedelic yeah it's heavier but it's
not matte it's heavier but it's not
metal to me yeah yeah but when it gets
hard
yes it just it you can feel it in your
[ __ ] phone
yes you know how it builds yes like in
the beginning I know it yeah right and
then it's like it builds and they're
like usually Papa only likes two-minute
song two minutes I'm out I never liked
the Grateful Dead I don't want anyone to
jam and g-minor for 21 minutes 50
minutes with [ __ ] tool so in my mind
and I'm saying this right now in my mind
they're probably in my top 10 of all
time hmm and for me yeah that's great
nothing about them and to have them in
the mix of the Velvet Underground yeah I
love Roxy music I love the Beatles of
stones all that stuff right yeah Pixies
I they're in that now you know in my
head and it's so and imagine not ever
seeing a Tarantino movie and being able
to see all nine not what eight of them
right yeah yeah right that's what it
feels like
yeah it's well there's a depth to it I
mean those bands that you're naming
there they aren't none of them were
making music to sell records they were
like no this is what we make yeah and if
people like it then they end up liking
it yeah that's what I love about to like
to make 10-minute songs from where
they're coming from people be like no
make them three minutes like make it
radio friendly not that that's even a
thing anymore but they're they're not
like that they're like no the natural
progression of the song that's just how
long this has two ends up being and they
aren't wasting your time because it
doesn't feel like 10 minutes yeah
remember when Chicago rebelled against
that song is inspiration and so they had
like a radio friendly version but if you
listen to the whole thing there's like a
seven-minute yes that has completely
unrelated to the balla that yeah you
play it all the time you know I love it
because it's so terrible it's not for
your inspiration it's not it's the other
that's it remember like when you thought
Peter Cetera
you're like oh he's like the lead singer
in Chicago and then you learn about
Chicago and you're like oh they had like
a badass guitarist leave yeah you know
about like are you a Chicago fan well I
like the earlier work but that's they
became baladi that's because David
Foster teamed up with Peter Cetera and
Lincoln yes yes say hey let get with the
times make your money with these
3-minute love ballad and they did I will
say they did crush those ballots but
that's not the band that lead singer had
a like scruffier voice and he was a
badass guitarist yeah it's like if
Anthony Kiedis died and they go call
Yanni
just now you went oh my god Jana that's
[Music]
also talking about how like comics when
we meet they're so accessible right yes
yes like you know we were out yesterday
I went to Sebastian Maniscalco